team jackson what's happening
so you remember our last video on derek
jackson
there's an update what's going on guys
derek jackson here
and today i am joined by my lovely wife
dania
and we just wanted to address a couple
of things you know we understand that
some of you may have already heard maybe
not
um that this chapter of our marriage is
one that
was preceded by marriage that i
completely failed
but the truth is and i'm saying it here
now is that derek jackson was involved
with other women
cheating affair stepping out um
definitely
not in alignment with the vows that i
took i've already told her
literally everything i've given her
basically a roll call list if i've said
hello to a woman in the last 12 years of
me knowing her she knows about it
i do not stand by those actions i don't
want to encourage anybody to do that
and then secondly i know that i cannot
build a platform
preaching certain things preaching
against certain things and then in my
real life
live contrary to that i'm also not a
victim nobody made me do this
uh she didn't make me push me to do it
the next person didn't make me no friend
influenced me it don't matter how i was
raising what trauma whatever
look i made decisions i made a series of
decisions that i gotta account for
there's no excuse of justification
i've already made that bed and have had
to lie in it um and now we're finally
getting on to the other side
personally in our own healing and our
own marital oneness
and now this is being made public to you
guys so we're bringing that forward to
you guys
and let you know where we're at with
that but did you want to say anything
um yes so i do want to just add that
i agree with what he just said there is
no justification for bringing other
women into
our marriage on any level and it was
unacceptable
and it's not something that i tolerate
or that we
tolerate moving forward and
when i i've been flooded again with
messages
and these things and about you know i
need to leave or why haven't i left
and the answer is when i found out about
it
i left i did not hesitate or waste time
to do so
and i stayed gone no matter how many
times he came
i stayed gone and stood firm on
i am not coming back and i did not
come back until i seen a shift in a
change in his mentality
and how he carried himself and how
he presented himself and in
conversations that we were able to have
that we had never been able to have in
just 12 years he is still continuing
to pursue god and continuing to seek
guidance in wise counsel from
men of god and that is
what i needed for the continuation
of me being present and in this marriage
and to stand by his side so today
where i'm at is at peace and i probably
stand by his
side and i get it some of y'all like
this may come as a huge shock
probably a huge disappointment i let a
lot of you down
no i wouldn't say this comes at a huge
shock
i'm personally upset because all right
black men don't cheat and you violated
that
i personally i wanted to have sympathy
for you i did but let me say this i have
no sympathy
for a man who finds it to be difficult
to be faithful
after being in a promiscuous lifestyle
and neither should you
nobody told you to be promiscuous before
the relationship and nobody made you be
monogamous with just her
you don't want her let another man have
her simple
but the truth is you've probably been
cheating months before you
actually put your dick in her and more
times i would say nine times out of ten
when the dude gets caught cheating that
was wasn't his very very first time
cheating
that wasn't his only time cheating that
was his only time getting caught
let's be real outweigh all the good that
you've done [ __ ]
that one slip up might cancel all the
[ __ ] that you've done you know you see
women in relationships with guys that
you know ain't gonna change and
you know they're in denial though yes he
will he'll figure it out et cetera et
cetera i think just getting rid of
that denial is the first major step
after that reverse engineering all the
things that you know went wrong
and then rooting back to like what
caused it so i had to go back to what
caused
the lack of sexual discipline it wasn't
just a lack of discipline it was
actually something i was looking for a
void i was trying to feel
to be clear this is an old interview
that he did a long time ago
well he's you're being real about that
but i mean you know and he grew he was
an evolved man but it turns out that he
was still into play play
amen today is not your day day you was
caught in a scandal
now you yelling for bait bang none of
you are here
to help this man when he calls for make
day hey boy
back in his heyday the man was a cheater
he was banging ladies over the heater
giving them that heat and then he want
to come like
let me put a ring on it then he saw
another girl he said let me put a ding
in it
and now we're getting on videos let me
put a sing in it but we not buying your
song
it's not even now cheating
black men don't cheat it's a problem for
me but moving on from just that
my friend my friend
you made a career on clowning black men
you made a career on passing yourself
off as that dude who's evolved
who's the ideal dude you clowned men
for a long time you guessed that man you
guys just don't want me to expose the
truth
and then you got exposed so of course
today you don't have to eat your crow
i don't care what happens within a
relationship y'all separate you cheat
all that stuff that's your business
but when you pass yourself off as a
preacher
as a man of god but it turns out that
you tubbing little boys behind the altar
yeah we gonna feel some type of way and
we're not saying that you did but it's
just not knowledge but yeah i'm saying
we know what i'm talking about you know
we know what i'm talking about
listen listen it's okay to give advice
but when you present this air like you
can't make mistakes
huh now we got a problem ain't that true
that's that's
that's the thing that's the thing that's
the thing that's the things you it's not
even
because we understand that humans are
human yes sir and things
happened that's that's why it's not in
my business none
i don't care that's why i don't engage
in the in in
those people that are known as gossip
things and saying
oh you know what happened with cardi and
this and that i don't care it's not my
business
things happen whatever you said it
yourself that you don't have any
sympathy
maybe you grew maybe you're going to
come back on that
but the money's already made the money's
done me mm-hmm
and it's okay that i don't know if
you're gonna have to come back on yours
well i can't wait to talk to you there
i can't because the money's made you
turn you got you got a whole following
preaching like you know what this and
that and those men and you are those men
this is what i'm saying the interview
looks a little bit weird her holding
your hand the whole setup you know what
i'm saying
like just you know hey you guys look at
that saying it looks odd
but you know what i'm i'm just different
i just think for me
the biggest thing is i don't think you
recognize some of the damage that you've
done in regards to the relation between
black men and
but as a changed man you knew how it was
you should have a little bit of empathy
you knew how it was
you knew you you were engaging in that
so
of course if you go like yeah no i'm a
change mess i'm good now
no you have to come back and with with
this empathy
that you know where it came what it is
it's like an alcoholic
would be going to like in the aaa
meeting i have no sympathy
for alcoholics i'm a change man not you
could relapse
that's not the problem relapsing is not
the problem
but you coming out from there and being
like
i don't have any sympathy for that if
you did that you did that you're that
that's right hey man you know i i'm more
annoyed because i have to hear women
like this just talk about you all the
time
what i actually want a man to do
somebody like
derek jackson like derek jackson is
always somebody um
he's always somebody that i liked simply
because
i knew he was a married black man to
a black woman like
he is a black man who looks the [ __ ]
good
he's married to a black woman who looks
the [ __ ] good
he is faithful to that black woman i i
just know that
based on because i i've had
conversations with him outside of that
outside of this
outside of the internet so like
and we have to hear that [ __ ] forever
but like derek man
i want to that's what i'm saying guys
people in gloves houses man y'all be
very careful i don't accept ammoniums
i've done some [ __ ] [ __ ] i know
right i did when i was single put you on
me i've done some [ __ ] i don't sell out
other dudes all that stuff and i don't
blame it all ladies but
what you did for a long time was you
pandered let's be honest
that's how everyone interprets it and
women hearing what you've done
they feel the same way now yeah they
feel the same way
so it's not just about you taking
accountability for
your actions that we don't care that's
your marriage what we got an issue with
is the image that you put out this kind
of ridiculous idea that you put in
everybody's head
right and then you don't think you've
created some damage
hypothetical and this is like none of my
business
but do you think he has no
other choice but to do what he's doing
right now what do you mean
well he's built his whole brand on the
idea of a faithful husband
who loves a black woman and does it so
diligently do you think
he could have afforded one before
everything broke because he probably
knew this was coming
do you think he could have afforded to
leave his wife and to go live his best
life
and maintain his brand yes how
who would listen to a man who cheated on
his wife
left her to go be a single bachelor
business-wise because that was his brand
his whole brand is i'm the
guy who you know i mean we're going to
talk about healing i'll be honest with
you maybe he really wants to do this but
there's also another side was like
ruff if you want to make money ever
again in this field you have no choice
but to do this
yes yeah i agree i agree and that's
probably the reason why you think this
setup is is weird and [ __ ] like that and
i get you
i'll get you i understand well it's like
it's like it's like are you are you
sorry
because of what you did or you're sorry
because you were definitely gonna get
cut and this is what i meant when i said
he's a bit disingenuous because he's out
here giving this advice meanwhile
out in the streets he's living a
completely different life for reasons
that are
very difficult or whatever but then he
looked at men like you could do better
and you know you can but bro you
couldn't do better you don't have a
reason
you couldn't do better wow you're asking
other folks to do things that you or
yourself didn't do
so that's my issue imagine you're
listening to an accountant
and he says don't do this don't do that
and you turn around
you know your accountant when your
accountant does fraud
you're like wow brother i can't listen
to you no more
yeah because because you told me to do
this do that save these
and you're out here frauding and sending
money out overseas and sh
and you're cut so i can't you can know
you can
lawyers that engage in in in in
criminal stuff they're not lawyers
anymore i
i can't wanna know why because there's
no trust in them they take an oath
let's go that's that's just what it is
if you wanna have a chit chat you can
come on a live with us we'll have a long
form discussion
uh because there's a lot of people who
wanna have longer form answers you don't
have to if you don't want to
uh but bruh you're done goofed that's
all i got but it's gonna be like you
come on
we're gonna do it respectfully but but
you know bro you know you know
[Music]
foreign foreign